et face aux dangers de la propagation
des responsables politiques de droite et
d'extrême droite réclame des contrôles
aux frontières françaises est ce
vraiment une solution l'europe doit-elle
apporter une réponse commune quelles
sont les mesures préconisées c'est
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir et
pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau avec philippe muray re
économistes souverainiste bonsoir
philippe muray rassure t bonds soir
patrick mennucci conseiller municipal de
marseille bonsoir et merci d'être là
vous aussi patrick mennucci à la je
m'adresse aux responsables politiques
est ce que c'est le cauchemar de tout
responsable politique une épidémie qui
menace son pays comme ça je sens
effectivement cette inquiétude et je
crois que les pouvoirs publics sont
mobilisés il me semble que dans la
situation dans laquelle on est il faut
éviter les complotisme les fausses
nouvelles il faut être vraiment faire
confiance à la science et en même temps
il faut prendre les mesures je donnais
vous disiez que des des dirigeants de
droite ou d'extrême-droite demandé la
fermeture faits ou des contrôles à la
frontière italienne honnêtement moi ça
ne me paraît pas être un sujet de
désaccord droite gauche paraît pas être
une mesure qui ne doit pas cependant si
elle ne sait s'il est nécessaire de la
pente mais il faut le faire
il me semble qu'il faut éviter comme
j'ai entendu ce matin madame buzet à
france inter
quasiment accusé anne hidalgo ne pas
avoir préparé la savoureuse
je parlais de la nuit
la nation par les deux ministres ce
qu'ils puissent que vous posez la tva si
elles doivent faire les hommes et les
femmes politiques dans cette
circonstance j'ai gardé beaucoup de
calme et éviter de me faire des sujets
de polémique politicienne voilà il me
semble que c'est ça qui doit être la
base de toute réflexion sur le sujet
dans ce cas c'est vrai que c'était plus
à droite qu'on demande s au contrôle des
frontières on va justement regarder ce
qu'on pensait marine le pen et eric
ciotti justement aujourd'hui ou demain
il faudra peut-être des contrôles aux
frontières le gouvernement doit pouvoir
le prévoir et je préfère qu'il en fasse
plus haut trop que pas assez
là pour l'instant il n'en fait pas assez
notamment permettant les vols en
provenance de chine pour protéger des
français j'ai écrit au premier ministre
pour lui demander un plan d'urgence et
des contrôles renforcés à la frontière
italienne
les alpes maritimes enregistrent un flux
quotidien de dizaines de milliers de
personnes avec l'italie 97 % des
médicaments sont actuellement fabriqués
à l'étranger et ne sont pas soumis au
contrôle européen
la propagation du coronavirus nous
appellent à une relocalisation des
laboratoires pharmaceutiques pour une
meilleure sécurité sanitaire des peuples
européens inscrits muraire de même son
contrôle des frontières une ré korir et
taurines davantage voilà c'est nuit par
par la droite
alors moi je dirais que je sentirai de
la droite et de la gauche mais la
politique de bon sens elle serait qu'on
aille très vite je pense qu'on devrait
déjà contrôler les frontières
sérieusement avec l'italie il ça fait
bien longtemps qu'on devrait avoir
arrêté les vols avec la chine
ou alors dévoile avec quarantaine quand
vous dites contrôler les frontières ça
veut dire quoi des contrôles de
température des pneus en température
voir effectivement les gens leur
expliquer puis surtout peut-être
restreindre aussi la circulation des
gens peut être restreint de touristes on
sait qu'il ya des touristes encore qui
se baladent coréen corée du sud sont
tous des touristes chinois aussi qui se
baladent et ça c'est pas simple parce
que si on se rappelle comment pourquoi
cette épidémie a échappé d'état chinois
on revient en arrière
autour du 15 janvier en fait
le laitage l'état de chinois a mis trop
de temps à fermer la frontière avec one
est à dire on confine one et à ce moment
là il ya cinq millions de personnes de
one la zone contaminée qui sont partis
et qui ont contaminé toute la chine est
maintenant qu'ils sont en train de
contaminer le monde entier donc on voit
qu'il faut des décisions très rapide
très clair très ferme et ne pas laisser
le temps justement par exemple des
italiens du nord qui a envie de se
déplacer ils vont se déplacer plus vite
ici avec un risque de porter le virus
etc
ces attentions c'est un moment qui va
être probablement qu'il va pas durer
très longtemps mais il faut prendre des
mesures parce que le but est d'épargner
des vies et dernier set propre et en
ayant ce en contrôlant nos frontières on
aide aussi les autres pays il faut que
les pays retrouve un petit peu de
sécurité à ce niveau là pour que le
virus se transmette pas d'un pays à
l'autre n'importe comment
je n'en avais une personne sur le début
de l'interview de marine le pen môme
choque pas je suis assez d'accord avec
ce que dit eric ciotti parce qu'eric
ciotti faut bien un dc10 il dit pas
fermeture des frontières et des
contrôles
on peut avoir un contrôle de température
très fraîche si c'est nécessaire et si
les évaluations au monde que c'est ça
qu'il faut le faire et mais il faut pas
oublier quand même par l'allemagne que
les italiens ont pris des mesures
puisqu'il ya 11
du nord de l'italie où les jeunes sont
confinés où donne théoriquement ils
peuvent pas se retrouver vous avez
regardé leurs outils j'ai pas regardé
journal de france 2 si le nôtre alors il
disait effectivement sur france 2 c'est
théoriquement confiné sauf que les
journalistes ont été envoyés ils sont
passés tout tranquillement le dimanche
soir dans la zone
effectivement les gens restés chez eux
mais c'était pas du tout confiné et tout
le monde pouvait rentrer sans rien je me
dis que moi je ne mange pas choqué par
une goutte drôle à la frontière et je
dire que dans ma vie personnelle à
l'heure j'ai excusez moi de parler de ça
j'ai été interpellé parce que mon fils
qui a 7 ans et qui est dans une école là
pas loin
marc a porté son cahier de
correspondance et donc il ya une mesure
de la ville de paris qui dit donc du
service scolaire la ville de paris anne
hidalgo qui dit que ceux ci seraient
allés en chine
on était en vacances ce qui serait très
en chine en corée du sud en iran en
voile à singapour elle est dans les deux
régions italiennes la vie
cernés il ya quatre mesures prises de
température les masques etc et surtout
une interdiction aux enfants de l'école
pendant 14 jours
il ya une espèce de 40 c'est sûr que
c'est quelque chose qu'il ya des lycéens
qui préparent le bac
est-ce que c'est pas tout pour les
enfants
alors là pourquoi que pour les ans mais
déjà c'est ça que je ne comprends bien
parce que déjà je pense que l'école dans
les bureaux non ça fait longtemps qu'on
a quitté les barbelés games
comment de ces faits non moi je
comprends que je peux je vois quand même
que des symptômes de mesures sont en
cours
après on peut se poser actuellement la
question des départs c'est sûr mais un
iphone qui seraient dans cette situation
qu'il serait donc déclarée à la ville de
paris
à l'aller 6 tutrice et je pense qu'on a
la capacité de remonter aux parents de
deux mois je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont allés en vacances fait
beaucoup de gens mettent pas les
septembre et en vacances qui ont pris
quelques jours l'italie du nord
il faut que je crois que chacun prenne
aussi sur lui c'est une affaire sérieuse
mais je pense que plus on saura dans la
danse dans la dot dans la science dans
la tranquillité et pas dans
l'agressivité pas dans la politique
politicienne plus son copain crasnault
nos concitoyens qui vaut être vigilant
sérieux et qu'il faut se plier peut-être
certaines choses ça c'est clair mais moi
je pense à moi je serai beaucoup plus
alarmiste que voue un culte début je
suis inquiet par cette épidémie parce
que ce qu'on voit faim depuis le début
depuis début février
ce qu'on voit c'est que la chine a mis
toutes les mesures en place possible et
des mesures anti liberty très forte que
peut prendre un régime véreux et quasi
dictature est déconfinement de one mais
d'autres régions sont confinés d'autres
villes beaucoup de villes les gens ne
sont pas des travaillé pendant quinze
jours il malgré tout le virus s'est
propagé de façon très rapide on voit
qu'en corée du sud la situation était
pas bonne mais pas si mauvaise que ça il
ya quatre cinq jours je crois qu'il y
avait 60 cas où quelque chose comme ça
et d'un coup
ça a démarré sur 600 cas et ce qui est
très clair et que cette épidémie c'est
qu'elle est
il vaut mieux l'arrêter tout de suite
avant qu'elles arrivent comme on l'a
fait jusqu'à comme ça s'est passé
jusqu'à maintenant plutôt que d'avoir un
certain nombre de malades est là que ça
devienne complètement irrémédiable
délits plus graves de la grippe
oui oui on a une main % de morts quand
même hein je veux dire donc il dans le
tableau msa 10 3% on peut donc c'est
pariant ce que s'attaquer immédiatement
les poumons
doté des personnes âgées
mais on a aussi les gens de 30 ans dao
beaucoup de médecins qui sont morts en
chine
et puis attention parce qu'elles se
propagent à une telle vitesse que je ne
crois pas une seconde aux chiffres
chinois qui sont annoncés plus qu'à
tours c'est vrai en tant qu'économiste
je vous le dis pourquoi en tant
qu'économiste je regarde souvent les
statistiques chinoises et un point sur
l'économie mondiale tous les deux mois
pour les statistiques chinoises ne sont
ne sont évidemment on ne peut pas
vraiment leur faire confiance
vous pouvez pas voir 6% de croissance
puis 5 098 5,8
un exemple tous ces chiffres sont lissés
tous ces chiffres sont travaillés et
contient une statistique qui commence à
déraper
généralement la chine arrête de la
sortir et là très clairement je vais
vous dire moi ce que je pense de ce
qu'on passe en chine il ya beaucoup plus
de l'état continuer à monter par contre
ils ont un problème majeur économique
puisque la chute des ventes de voitures
ces 92 % et pas qu'eux et pax arrêts et
l'immobilier et je pense qu'ils font le
choix de se dire il faut bien quand même
qu'on produise un petit peu qu'on
produise la nourriture pour alimenter et
puis pour pas tuer complètement
l'économie et je pense qui minore
légèrement les chiffres c'est une
possibilité
et c'est d'autres d'épidémiologistes
qu'idc des épidémiologistes qui dit ça
probablement pour lâcher un peu de lest
et pourra voir l'économie qui repart un
peu parce que là le risque c'est d'avoir
des millions de faillite en chine et un
problème économique vraiment gravissime
si neil patrick mennucci vous vous
partagez cette suspicion
si peu si vous voulez les les pays
les organisation totalitaire les
chiffres qu'il donne sont toujours
soumis à l'étude c'est un leader
il n'y a que dans les pays comme la
france la plupart du temps les choses
sont réels on dit en en temps je ne sais
pas si c'est vrai que il ya eu un
contrôle de la de l'épidémie un chien
qui a été fait bon si c'est le cas tant
mieux mais au fond la question est ce
que les verrines le véritable danger
aujourd'hui c'est pas plutôt le
moyen-orient l'afrique ou alors là il
est les systèmes rico sont peut-être
défectueux qu'un chine
et là on risque effectivement d'abord
neymar alors je trouve qu'une des choses
qui manquent et ont discuté de la
dangerosité et ccd vraie explication
dessus pour l'instant on entend très peu
comme vous je regarde mon alerte et au
journal de france 2 et c'est vrai que je
vois assez peu d'explications sur qu'est
ce que c'est cette maladie en fait et
qu'est ce que sow et conséquences s p c
est ce qu on peut en mourir quand on est
déjà atteint on a dit que pas un peu des
jeunes qui sont généralement c'est
plutôt ça dure trois à six semaines on
le sait c est à peu près 15 % des
malades qui se retrouve avec une
pneumonie
golasa sévère et alors 500 son état
alors que la grippe a c'est plutôt 3% et
0 1%
non je parle qui se retrouve dans une
situation difficile et lorsque c'est
vrai que 2 % ça paraît pas grand chose
tout le monde est affecté en france ça
fera quand même un million de morts le
pen est en effet passé qu'est ce que
pourrait faire la vie marine le pen
c'est marine le pen elle fait de la
politique
après on peut faire la politique et dire
des choses comme bandama question de le
contrôler nos frontières ne me paraît
pas un acte end et cette raison je
trouve qu'elle a raison là dessus parce
que
états unis interdisent les vols de la
chine depuis le début février
et je trouve que ça aurait dû être fait
en france la même manière hong kong
interdit les vols aussi vers de la chine
où mais les gens en quarantaine forcée
des résidents la corée du sud aussi et
nous je trouve qu'on est des grands
bisous nous rien laxisme moi je trouve
ça un bac 6 et c'est même une trahison
des français parce qu'on met les
français en danger
alors je quand j'entends l'union
européenne qui dif en fait l'important
c'est de se coordonner
est ce qui pourrait arrêter une réunion
d'ailleurs ce soir un déni faudrait
arrêter avec leur idéologie le bon sens
c'est pas de se coordonner ces des gens
d'agir chacun son équivalent mais chacun
avec nos attentes et à sion et c'est
bien à son échelle chacun avec ses
moyens
chacun avec sa géographie chaque avec
ses problèmes en se coordonnant pour la
gestion des frontières
c'est ça le principal d'éviter des morts
d'éviter que ça se propage
parce que la chance qu'on a de se sortir
de ce virus qu'on n'en sait rien et
c'est une chance que je virus se
transmette moins bien au moins pendant
les mois chauds
donc il faut qu'on tienne cette épidémie
jusqu'au mois d'avril parce que la
probable il y a une chance assez forte
comme pour le sarthe ce virus soit
beaucoup moins dangereux et
transmissible à ce moment là sinon c'est
quand même les pandémies en mondial est
quelque chose de pas drôle du tout si
les bourses s'effondrent
s'il aura pris les sites 6 ou à sélestat
de miss qui parle mais alors c'est vrai
que la bourse de milan a fini sur un
plongeon cinq points 43% se soit pas
très étonnant
mais je veux dire la bourse d'abord le
monde souvent ne sais pas pourquoi mais
là où c'est pourquoi le dessin m
voilà il ya une baisse de la
consommation si vous avez fermé les
jeunes chez eux
l'italie et aux communes apparemment qui
sont dans cette situation donne des
communes qui sont à 55 kilomètres de
milan dans la zone industrielle
voilà donc c'est tout à fait logique
mais je compterai réponse de paris aussi
à baisser parce que s'il ya une baisse
des relations
commercial avec la chine et il y aura
obligatoirement dans les deux sens
d'ailleurs et c'est d'ailleurs plus les
chinois sans doute qui sont impactés que
nous et ça aura des conséquences sur les
entreprises françaises
j'ai dernièrement sur l'europe je
connais le système c'est toujours la
faute à l'europe et sa monnaie
mais là en l'occurrence sur ce sujet
l'art et la responsabilité est aux états
il n'y a pas de responsabilité
européenne
la décision de fermer la frontière à la
partie ils disent qu'il faut un discours
donné vous disent qu'ils ont raison mais
non mais vous fermez une frontière vous
passez par la suisse et vous revenez en
france
l'union européenne a dit la commission à
peine dit je vais vous faire un plan moi
je pense qu'ils vont faire un plan moi
je connais l'ensemble des pays c'est pas
une c'est pas forcément effectivement
leur compétence exclusive mais n'empêche
qu'ils se mêlent de tout après vienne
nous expliquer qu'il faut pas fermer les
frontières
pas de panique etc non parce qu'il
faudrait arrêter j'aimerais vous
imaginez que me dirigeais revient dans
la télévision et 10 les gars il faut
attendre panique ex nord mais on avait
besoin de rallye qui livre la vérité
c'est difficile d'être responsables
politiques
cette espèce de deux lignes très fébrile
entre eux
on n'a pas paniqué et vous exprimer ces
réseaux mais je faisais juste ont marqué
que je sais qu'on met l'europe à toutes
les sauces et que l'europe est
responsable de tout il ya même une
technique que vous consiste à mettre
tellement de responsabilités sur
l'europe qu'on a exonéré nos dirigeants
de leur propre aux responsables et le
fond 1-1 voilà non mais très souvent on
y avait le c'est pas la faute du
président n'a pu que prévu sa faute
d'europe
or la 10e puis ce qu'on est en train
d'en discuter les mesures qui peuvent
être prises et celles que vous réclamez
les mesures de sûreté de contrôle etc ça
ce sont des mesures qui émaneront du
ministre de la santé
louise derrière du produit très plaisir
d'un public
c'est notre responsabilité c'est
responsabilité de la france donc il vaut
mieux savoir au début de cette
affaire-là
plutôt que de laisser penser que
l'europe à de gaulle alors à faire afin
de dire monsieur mais non je le dis
qu'elle prépare à blanc elles courent
c'est non mais je me perds la vérité je
ne sais pas ce que dit ce qu'elle veut
mais une pression elle fait une pression
pour dire coordonnées vous ne faites etc
il faut bien mais sur soi ce soir
effectivement il ya une réunion des
ministres pour trouver la maison comme
lieu d'être à bruxelles en train de se
réunit à trouver une solution commune
ils feraient bien d'être dans leur pays
pour travailler ils n'ont pas besoin de
dix ans pour se coordonner
c'est à chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités à ses deux camarades non
c'est pas de la démocratie c'est à dire
sinon on a des gens qui ne savent que
vous êtes très bien comme peut avoir
déjà à bruxelles de discuter d'autres
appareils tout et pour nourrir la
conversation va écouter l'avis du
médecin général 15 et qui étaient avec
nous on dirait que tout à l'heure pour
lui ces mesures de contrôles aux
frontières ont un intérêt politique
davantage j'ai seulement on est encore
dans une phase en france on peut isoler
les patients la fenêtre de tir elle va
être relativement courte parce que on
voit bien qu'en italie ils sont à plus
de 200 cas plus on a des cas qui se
multiplient plus l'enjeu n'est plus
finalement de les isoler mais vraiment
de les traiter et voyez bien si on a
plusieurs centaines de patients ça va
être compliqué de les isoler
on n'imagine pas pour la grippe par
exemple isolé tout le monde dans cette
mesure de contrôle des frontières voire
de fermeture des frontières je pense pas
qu'en france on puisse fermer les
frontières mais elle aura côté
symbolique qui serait peut-être pas
inutile ce contrôle de température ne
serait ce que pour rassurer les gens
mais on est bien d'accord que sur le
plan médical c'est pas ça qui empêchera
la diffusion du virus ce virus il est
très contagieux on le voit en italie on
sait même pas quel est le patient zéro a
calé le patient source ce virus il est
il a été transporté véhicules et de
chine
et on voit bien que ça paraît
extrêmement difficile de maintenir une
situation hermétique en france avec zéro
cas sur le territoire à pratiquement
zéro ça il peut continuer à débattre bon
pas rassurant quand même le docteur qui
recèle qui pourtant était assez
rassurant il ya deux semaines mais enfin
il change alors oui je cours qui dit la
vérité là la fermeture des frontières ou
le contrôle de la de la température ça
sûrement un effet qui montre à la
population qui a une prise en compte de
cette affaire qui appelle chacun un peu
responsables vous avez entendu le bus
coincés à lyon toute la journée
s'il ya bien là tout comme chinoise qui
est arrivé dans un commissariat
aujourd'hui qui plus est on a fermé
commissariat qu'il se trouvait qu'elle
avait rien n'a été juste chinoise est
puissante et moi je dois d'aider damas
pharmacie acheter des masques
pascal au zoo une minute et une
philippine à la maison je laime tenu de
mes oreilles et donc des abris on n'a
pas fini d'en notamment beau mais je
crois qu'il faut tout simplement qu'on
garde dans le match parce que c'est
drôle
les hommes politiques et les pommes 8 et
qu'il faut à la fois a complètement la
situation n'est pas dans les mesures les
plus drastiques qu'on ne doit pas me
mettre les hôpitaux une situation c'est
ça la véritable question est ce que les
chu sont en situation
c'était c'est ce qu'on a les moyens
aujourd'hui avec la crise les urgences
le monde mais bien vous lire je sais
bien ce programme mais il y aura des
réquisitions 6 et la nécessité absolue
mais notre manque déjà de lit je le sais
donc ce qui montre qu'il ya un problème
de sous dimensionné son service
hospitalier comme on est en train de le
faire a coupé à coup d'austérité et
qu'on va peut-être le payer là dessus
mais moi je veux dire il faut pas
paniquer effectivement mais si on veut
réduire
il fallait réduire augmenter les
contrôles aux frontières interdire le
voyage avec la chine il ya énormément de
gens potentiellement contaminés en chine
il suffit qu'ils aient trois quatre cinq
personnes qui passent sous les radars et
on n'y arrive plus parce que le problème
de cette maladie c'est 80 % des gens
n'ont pas de symptômes
ils le ressentent comme un rhume et
après il ya 20% dès gens qui ont des
problèmes beaucoup plus graves mais il y
avait 80 80 % c'est rien du tout c'est
une toux etc et donc ils le savent pas
ils vont contaminer énormément de gens
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il fallait
faire contrôler les frontières avant
mais ça malheureusement
je veux dire il ya une telle idéologie
sans frontière est fermée des frontières
c'est presque un drame c'est presque un
drame pour notre pays
donc parce que on a l'impression que
c'est une catastrophe
alors que c'est une mesure scène ça se
passe très bien aux états unis ils ont
fermé les frontières avec la chine y
sont très de l'argent si la faire en
temps un peu critiqué mais en face on a
l'habitude avec les russes
les chinois de critiquer tout le monde
les chiffres sont pas contents que les
états unis aient fait ça mais je veux
dire on peut les comprendre mais on est
obligé de se protéger des uns les autres
et je pense que quand un pays comme les
etats unis se protègent ils se protègent
de l'épidémie pour lui il protège des
autres pays du monde ne pas avoir
l'épidémie aux états unis et de la
transmettre ailleurs street mais nous si
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas un peu niais
idéologie sur ce côté roula le gros mot
on ferme les frontières on ne regardait
l'étrange j'avais à donner le le métier
mairie qui a craqué j'ai des idées c'est
si vous fermez la frontière il dit c'est
très bien parce qu'une d'ailleurs il
renonce pas il dit vous pouvez la fermer
c'est une mesure qui est plus politique
que sanitaire parce que nous avons fait
des pas que ça une icône de ça réduit un
petit peu et qui serait un petit peu
décimé de virus y passe avec les gens là
tiens elle n'a pas tous aller il dit
aussi que c'est pas imprenables
températures déjà parce que comme vous
l'avez dit pas de caisse de jours latifa
terroristes alors qu'est ce qu'il faut
pas arrêter la berge reliant gagner la
france qu'on a lorsque les questions
c'est ben y'a pas que du tourisme
prudent mais que déjà le régime rappelle
juste qui a 15 ans d'établir une côtés
d'autres et ils n'ont rien de niçois qui
travaille sur la riviera italienne fai
sai cause ces quatre mois jeu mais s'il
faut le faire il faut le faire assez
forte mais j'adore ça je comprends pas
mais par eric ciotti que je connais très
bien et je connais sonangol je meurs sur
ces sujets de de frontières extérieure
c'est bien le 2 qui demandent pas faire
voiture les frontières et des douanes de
l'eau control parce qu'il cale au
minimum lui c'est comme président
nicoals et départementales isolement
dire après si effectivement la situation
save anime ce sera si vous savez ici
si malheureusement il faut quelque 3000
frontaliers puisse pas les travaillé
pendant quinze jours pour protéger de
soi pour maîtriser sur les noms si vous
avez des 100kg 65 mm
mais ça serait une essence rainbow
l'erreur de la chine on est en train de
la refaire ils ont laissé one comme ça
non confiné pendant trop longtemps et
derrière ça posait des problèmes à ja il
faut pas la faire deux fois
merci messieurs merci et philippe muray
et patrick mennucci d'avoir des battus
on se retrouve donc